quand j'étais ce conservatoire
j'avais un professeur de littérature que
j'aimais beaucoup
il m'aimait beaucoup aussi vous pensez
bien que j'en abuse et un de mes défauts
j'en avais beaucoup c'était mon côté
indiscipline et surtout sur l'horaire
les cours commencé à 10 heures j'arrive
air très régulièrement vers 11 heures un
jour j'arrive à la gare saint-lazare
terreur il était midi moins le quart
je suis naturellement très anxieuse de
ça je me dis cette fois mappy il faut
trouver une excuse mais un grand coup
frappé un grand coup
une idée germe dans ma tête je me dis
qu'est ce que je peux dire à mon vieux
professeur pour qu'il soit tout à fait
impressionné je remonte la rue de rome
et dans le couloir du conservatoire je
défais mes cheveux un peu mon corsage
aussi j'entre dans la classe une classe
sidéré de me voir
cycle art parce que quand même c'était
il était 11h45
je vois mon copain des richards ont
démarré qui tous étaient quand même très
silencieux impressionné par ce retard
qui était le sait pas le le dixième le
15e retard je me mets devant le
professeur en accuser et je lui dit l'un
pied dans la tombe
mais il ne faudrait pas marcher sur
l'autre non
on va commencer je lui dit m
je ne peux pas je ne peux pas vous
expliquer ce qui m'est arrivé dans le
métro
j'aurais dû
j'ai dit mais quoi quoi qu'est ce qui
était arrivé encore j'étais violent tout
de sidérer apprend sobre il m'a dit
petit mais comment mais il n'y avait
personne
genest m c'est un wagon presque vide et
4 boillon août essayé de m'embrasser
alors je me suis battu et vous pensez
bien que je me suis défendu comme j'ai
pu voilà dans quel état je suis la
classe a beaucoup ri après mais hélas
moi j'ai des remords qui est dans la
tombe et il faudrait pas marcher sur
l'eau